[Music]
all right you're doing fine sweetie
now uh malia let's just go easy on the
gas here and come to a complete stop
okay so in the future you want to try
not to go through stop signs
just remain calm now and uh what you're
going to want to do is pull up right
here uh next to the curb
this is why we want to stay in the lines
and we want to follow rules
remember this
license and registration
holy
mr president yeah yeah just uh teaching
malia to drive
well you guys ran a stop sign back there
but that's okay you can go oh no no no
no well malia's got to learn what it's
like to drive in the real world here
well this is called consequences malia
now i want you to go ahead and treat us
like you would if i weren't the
president
not exactly what i had in mind
thank you and may god bless america
all right couple introductions with your
chat here this is john o'rourke nice to
meet you john mr ian roberts nice to
meet peter tencio all right nice to meet
you jerome smith come on brother what's
up fam
you know this keith williamson nice to
meet you mary woodbury nice to meet you
jay martel nice to meet you sir tasha
robinson come on come on come on
feel that emily george all right
nice to meet you daryl stokes come on
what's up fam how you doing all right
never forget about that cause that's all
we got
nice to meet you all right
starting from the bottom now we're here
yeah
nice to meet you
all right nice to meet you all right
last time
one eighth black afternoon my octoroon
come on bring it in there yeah i'm in
the dog i'm in there
nice to meet you man
nice to meet you oh my goodness look at
this oh
she is so
beautiful um
i want another one there you go precious
beautiful beautiful what's her name oh
this is livia roojie okay nice to meet
you miss rushy
all right
come on there he is
boom
all right very good to meet you all
right here we go right this way sir
[Music]
oh
hi
that wasn't expecting to see you all
undulating up here uh hi i just uh put
my jacket on the bed when i first came
to the party but uh i didn't realize
that the party made its way up here but
i'll get that now i will if you uh carol
i don't know if you're
in there somewhere but uh wherever you
are thank you for the invitation i
really enjoy myself i see you at work
tomorrow okay hey sir i think i see my
jacket i think i think your arm is in
the sleeve actually i'll grab that's not
my jacket and that's not your arm it's
not your arm white people are crazy
white people are crazy just looking for
a jacket sir okay yeah very nice
mustache i've never seen one above the
nose that's interesting that's not your
nose okay sorry to uh disturb you sir
just looking for a jacket just the
ordinary man looking for a jacket you
want to say something to me sir are you
trying oh come on
no thank you very much sir it tasted a
little bit like salty but but that's
okay it's tweed the jacket i'm talking
about and it's got leather patches on it
just oh maybe this is it thank you found
it and nope that's not it but
congratulations man you are doing great
with what god gave you nope don't look
at me in the eyes ma'am i don't want you
to steal my soul hi ladies nice to meet
you and sir yes i do see you too okay
yeah that's why people are craving oh no
i'm okay i really am i'm uh already
seeing a a group of people and we're
taking it slowly we are taking it slowly
it's a church maybe some of y'all would
be interested in looking into that not
mine but one somewhere if that's okay
thank you ma'am for there it is i found
it found the jacket it's right here i'm
gonna pull it and i believe it might be
lodged somewhere
within you i'm just guessing because
that is just a
little bit of resistance all right there
we go and you know what that is going to
be yours keep it thank you cover
yourself up carol if you're in there
i'll see you at the office tomorrow just
bring the bowl you can finish the egg
salad my god white people
now first
let me just say that i'm encouraged that
so many of you from the republican party
have
agreed to meet me in this way
now as you know i've tried very hard to
reach across the aisle
and govern this country from the middle
well
all due respect mr president
we disagree with you
we think you should run the country from
not the middle
well that's why we're here
if you would i'd just appreciate some
feedback on some new ideas and
directions for this country feel free to
agree or disagree
whatever you want
we're gonna disagree
disagree
disagree
first
i think the government is too big
i think we need to shrink the size of
the federal government so that all
decisions can be made at the state level
we disagree mr president
you drive a hard bargain you win
we go
big government it is
next up
this has been a hot button issue but i
think we can settle it right here
no taxes
for rich people we completely disagree
round two goes to you guys
okay
more taxes for the rich
what the
what is happening to us man i am taking
a beating here guys all right last issue
immigration
now
we need to secure our borders
and anybody who's here illegally should
be hunted down and deported
[Music]
if we disagree
[Music]
we are a country of immigrants no
we need a clear path to citizenship for
all of those who are already here
help me
[Music]
great i love your ideas lastly we cannot
regulate firearms
all right all right
you guys say so
and nobody better throw me a cigarette
[Music]
ain't i a stinker
all y'all rappers out there think y'all
hard cause what y'all been through
hey y'all
check it out it was friday night
chilling on my front lawn me and my crew
i had my bathrobe on everybody high just
watched x-men got plenty chicken heads
ready for sex man musters roll up they
trying to talk smack don't these know
they [ __ ] with them
i knew homie seen us he pulled two shots
somehow my penis got between us i got
shot
[Music]
still standing
went back to my palace fast
now i'm the dude walking around with a
phallus cast like wolverine i'm trying
to be a loner but they think a got an
adamantium boner what can i say they
still up on my totem pole [ __ ] get your
tongue ring away from the scrotum hole
don't know why they love it but it keeps
the ladies moistening gave half the
[Music]
[Music]
still standin
[Music]
yo they shot that fool in that
[Music]
man damn
that hurts
damn no video over man video's over
i'm serious man
damn
hey girl
i'm home hey boo how you doing
good how was work
sucked oh
can i ask you a quick question yeah sure
what up
i just been noticing that every time i
leave to go out the next time i open the
computer the browser history's been
cleared
hmm
that's weird yesterday i went food
shopping for like 15 minutes i used the
computer before i went to the store and
when i came back my history was gone the
cache was cleared and the cookies have
been reset
huh
well
i think sometimes the computer runs an
automatic software update so maybe that
just kind of clears the history
yeah except when you update the software
a little window pops up and you click ok
and then it gets installed so
hmm
i don't know maybe there's something
wrong with the computer you know and
it's just one of those things whenever
it gets interrupted from the power
source it has to reboot and it just
totally wipes out the history
be honest babe it's porn right
what's
oh pornography no
it's okay if you look at porn i assumed
you did anyways i mean every guy does
i'm perfectly okay with that as long as
it's not that weird stuff
oh
all right well i mean kiki's okay i like
kinky
as long as it's not that sick twisted s
m stuff
wow
um
okay i'm not gonna judge your journey it
is your fantasy just as long as you're
looking at women
who
not women
wow
okay
men
chicks with dicks
horses
worse than horses
wow
baby give me a little credit
none of that matters the only thing that
matters that when we're doing it i'm
thinking about you
and you're thinking about me right
right
baby you go
excuse me
oh excuse me sir are you sitting in 26 g
yes have i done something wrong no no no
no we just wanted to ask if you would
mind switching seats so that a mother
and a child could sit together
but
i'm back there right yeah but you'd
actually be sitting here
[Music]
which is an economy plus
um it's actually an upgrade
upgrade you
say economy plus
yes sir oh
don't mind if i do great great uh carry
on
carry on yourself alex
thank you
the economy plus
oh for the discerning passengers
we're not in kansas anymore
ladies and gentlemen this is your
captain speaking we should be leaving
topeka in the next 10 minutes i stand
corrected
looks like we're gonna have a smooth
flight trust me i know the captain and
he's one smooth guy
[Music]
of course he knows the captain
he is the captain
oh
move over colin mockery there's a new
face in the biz
his name is captain
[Music]
have to be an economy plus to get it i
guess
[Music]
extra foot room
one inch at least
[Music]
sky shop magozine
[Music]
dorado
oh the dog ear from my convenience
lord of the rings cops
lord of the rings tables
holy shatsu massage
economy plus
it hurts a little bit
but i like it
[Music]
and i thought i had an upgrade
lil wayne y'all
the carter
yeah yeah yeah
i'm coming to y'all straight from rikers
penitentiary [ __ ]
you heard me hey man
haters out there think i'm playing think
i'm some kind of joke man yeah young man
that hell yeah check this out right here
man
i'm a badass [ __ ] on this whole
prison here [ __ ] yeah you heard check
it out let's go i'm the baddest dude
[Music]
lil wayne
that's right yeah yeah yeah cause i'm
coming for y'all you know what's up man
i run this yeah in fact yo let's go i'm
the baddest where you going man where
you going hey man where you going you
ain't got to go
[Applause]
ah okay i see pick on the little guy huh
punks
hey
i have this little ironic come on right
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo
[Music]
who you gonna call
[Music]
hi i'm ray parker jr writer and
performer of the academy award-nominated
head single
ghostbusters from the major motion
picture ghostbusters but that's just one
song i've written so many other major
motion picture theme songs and submitted
them throughout the year
now they're available and together for
one specially priced compilation
songs like you tried to play the game
but it's driving you insane
jumanji
danger in the jungle jumanji
there's lying in my house
come on mr computer
throw me a bone i said lawn mower man
get up off of my lawn
when armageddon is near you better get
out of here
[Music]
i ain't afraid to know story
it's getting legal y'all these songs
have only been heard by the highest
level of industry decision makers but
now you can feel like a hollywood
executive in your own home
i see your face off
that guy walking around it's a face off
that ain't even your face
passing on the cries
give me that off for this cross
passing on the christ you know my daddy
is the boss
to serve me yeah
that's not even a word
[Music]
now there's a whole lot of kinky that
that room is stinky
50 shades of grey
all right white people
who's a slave
i'm not a slave whoa oh
[Music]
there's one thing i know
is that persistence makes perfection
sure hollywood missed out but that
doesn't mean you have to
down in the basement
what's going on
it's uh
there's a kid and a nazi down there
[Music]
order now to receive your free copy of
bobby sings the twos theme songs to
sequels that were never made
you will be in room 237
and you have free wi-fi there
also from 6am to 10am every morning
there's a free continental breakfast
continental breakfast yes from 6am to 10
a.m
so it's continental then
very good
like garcon
a one
uh admission for the continental
breakfast you can just help yourself sir
oh
interesting european style
[Music]
when in
rome
[Music]
the forbidden fruit
well aren't you a tiny plum
well la
dee
da
[Music]
vapor and everything and who are you
my little friend
not a spoon
not a fork but something in between
a fuppoon
[Music]
what will you think of next germany
all the european countries lay before me
where should i fly to first
the pit of the donut
thank you turkey
buckle up
let's see where we shall go next ah the
danish
clearly from brussels um
hello grease
where the yogurt flows like water
yes
like go good but to stay
so good
pulling into spain
[Music]
baked to perfection can you believe this
it all comes with the room
[Music]
i love being incontinent
i love being in congress and the light
of the senses isn't it my friend
isn't it
yes
i have what i'm having
what i'm having
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's so
good
oh good afternoon sir how can i help you
well
davis i will be staying
indefinitely
but sir don't you know that you've
always been here
[Music]
really
[Music]
continental breakfast
right around the corner
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]